welcome back
here we go again great to see you and
congratulations thank you um you will
never forget what is going on in the
world when you think about when your
child is born you will know for the rest
of this child's life you were born
during a weird time that's for sure
that is for sure
they're probably the weirdest that i can
remember
uh yeah yeah um and he was born on uh
may the fourth and yeah that's hilarious
too yeah may the fourth be with him yeah
exactly it has to be hopefully i sure
hope so perfect yes i mean that was the
perfect day for you
and
how do you say the name
well uh is it a placeholder first of all
my partner is the one that actually
mostly came up with the name
congratulations to her yeah yeah she's
great at names um so
i mean it's just
x the letter x
um and then
the ae is like pronounced ash
yeah
and then
a12 a12 is my contribution
oh why a12 uh archangel 12 the precursor
to the sr-71 coolest plane ever
that's true i i agree with you i don't
know i'm not familiar with it i know
what the sr-71 is yeah yeah yeah i know
what that is so the sr71 came from a cia
program uh
called archangel oh it's the archangel
project
and then archangel 12. oh wow what a
dope-looking plane yeah
oh okay i got it yeah well as a person
who's uh
very much into uh
aerial travel as you are that's uh
perfect that's pretty great yeah pretty
great
um
so is it does it feel strange to have a
child while this craziness is going does
it feel like you've had children before
is this any weirder
uh it's actually i think it's better uh
being older and having a kid i
appreciate it more
um yeah
babies are awesome they are pretty
awesome they're awesome yeah when i
didn't have my any of my own i would see
other people's kids and i didn't not
like them sure but i wasn't drawn to
them sure but now when i see little
people's kids i'm like oh i think of
them like these little love packages
yeah little love bugs yeah it's just you
you think of them differently when you
see them come out and then grow and then
eventually start talking to you
like your whole idea what a baby is is
very different yeah so now as you you
know get older and get to appreciate it
as a mature
fully formed adult
it must be really
pretty wonderful yeah
wonderful it's great but babies are
awesome yeah yeah that's uh that's great
um
yeah um
i mean also i've i've spent a lot of
time on ai and neural nets and so you
can sort of see
the kind of the brain develop which is
you know what
an ai neural net is trying to simulate
what a brain does basically um and you
can sort of see the
it
learning very quickly
you know it's just wow
see things fire so you're talking about
the neural net you're not talking about
an actual baby i don't know about
actually an actual baby but both of them
yes but the word neural net comes from
the the brain it's like a
net of neurons
so
you know it's like the
yeah
humans are the
you know original gangster the neural
net
that's a great way to put it yeah so
when you're
programming artificial intelligence
where you're working with artificial
intelligence art
are they specifically trying to mimic
the developmental process of a human
brain
in a lot of ways there's some ways that
are different um you know an analogy
that's often used is like you know we we
don't make
a submarine swim like a fish
but we take the principles of of how
you know what of hydrodynamics and apply
them to a submarine i've always wondered
as a lay person do you try to achieve
the same results as a human brain but
through different methods or do you try
to copy the way a human brain achieves
results
i mean the essential elements of
an ai neural net are
really very very similar to a
human brain neural net yeah
it's having the multiple layers of
neurons and
you know back propagation these all
these things are what your brain does
you know it's sort of
yeah um
you have a layer of neurons that goes
through a series of intermediate steps
to ultimately cognition and that and
then it'll
reverse those steps and go back and
forth and go all over the place
um
it's um
yeah it's it's
interesting very interesting
yeah i would imagine
like the thought of programming
something that is eventually going to be
smarter than us
that one day it's going to be like why
did you do it that way
like when artificial intelligence
becomes sentient they're like oh you
tried to mimic yourself like this so
much better process cut out all this
nonsense
but like there are elements that are the
same but just almost like like an
aircraft does not fly like a bird
right yeah it doesn't flap its wings
but the wings
the way the wings work and generate lift
is the same as bird
now you're
in the middle of this uh
this strange time where you're selling
your houses you say you don't want any
material possessions and i've been
seeing all that and i've been really
excited to talk to you about this yeah
because it's an interesting thing to
come from a guy like yourself
like why are you doing that
i'm slightly sad about it actually
but
if you're sad about it why are you doing
it
i think i think possessions kind of
weigh you down
then they're kind of an attack vector
you know people say hey billionaire you
got all this stuff like well and now i
don't have stuff now what are you gonna
do
attack vector meaning like people target
it yeah um interesting yeah
but you're obviously gonna so you're
gonna rent a place yeah
okay
and get rid of everything except clothes
no i said like almost everything
so it's like keep a couple teslas
yeah sure yeah kind of have to
test product and stuff um
yeah those things that have sentimental
value for sure are keeping those here um
yeah so do you feel like
what's worse that could happen right
you're fine
yeah you could always buy more stuff if
you don't like it
especially yeah i mean from the money
that you sell all your stuff you could
buy new stuff
but do you you feel like
people
define you by the fact that you're
you're wealthy
and that they define you in a pejorative
way
for sure i mean not everyone but right
you know there's uh
for sure in recent like years
billionaire has become a per jar like
it's in a projective so like it's like
that's a bad thing um
which i mean i think doesn't make a lot
of sense in most cases if you've if
you're done if you basically
uh
organized a
company like see like how do how does
this wealth arise it's if you organize
people in a in a better way to produce
products and services that are better
than what existed before
and you have
some ownership in that company then that
that essentially gives you the right to
allocate more capital
so it's there's a conflation of
consumption and capital allocation
so
let me say warren buffett for example
and to get totally frank i'm not his
biggest fan but
uh
you know he does a lot of capital
allocation
um and he reads a lot of a lot of sort
of annual reports of companies and
all the accounting and it's pretty
boring really um and he's trying to
figure out is
does coke or pepsi deserve more capital
i mean that's
i mean it's kind of a boring job if you
ask me um
but
uh you know it's still a thing that's
important to figure out like which is a
company deserving of more or less
capital should that company grow or
expand is it making products and
services that are
better than others or worse and you know
should
you know
if a company is making compelling
products and services it should get more
capital and if it's not it should get
less we'll go out of business well
there's a big difference too between
someone who's making an incredible
amount of money designing and
engineering fantastic products versus
someone who's making an incredible
amount of money by
investing in companies or moving money
around in the stock market or doing
things along those lines
it's it's a different thing and to put
them all in the same category seems
it's it's very simple and as you pointed
out it's an attack vector yeah for sure
yeah i mean i think it's it's really
i i do think they're
in the in the united states especially
there's an over allocation of talent uh
in finance and law
uh basically too many smart people go
into finance and law
so
you know this is both a compliment and a
criticism
we should have of i think fewer people
doing law and fewer people doing finance
and more people making stuff
yeah yeah well that would certainly be
better for all involved if they made
better stuff yeah yeah absolutely um
and and you know manufacturing used to
be highly valued in the united states
and these days it's not it's it's often
looked down upon which i think is wrong
yeah
well i think that people are kind of
learning that
particularly because of this whole
pandemic and this relationship that we
have with china
that it there's a lot of value into
making things into making things here
yes somebody's got to do the the real
work yeah you know and um
you know
like making a car it's an honest days
that's not honest day is living that's
for sure
you know or making anything really or
providing valuable service
um like providing you know greater
entertainment good information but these
are all valuable things to do um
you know so yeah there should be more
more of it did you have a moment where
is this something that this idea of
getting rid of your material possessions
is something that built up over time or
did you have a moment of realization
where you realize that
yeah i've been thinking about it for a
while
um
you know part of it is like i
like have a bunch of houses but
i don't spend a lot of time in
most of them and
that doesn't seem like a good use of
assets like somebody could probably be
enjoying those houses and get better use
of them than me so don't you have gene
wilder's house i do that's amazing
that's awesome wow
exactly what you'd expect did you
request that the buyer not [ __ ] it up
yeah that's a requirement
oh a requirement that's that's a good
requirement yeah not in that case in
that house yeah it'll probably sell for
last but still i don't care uh he's a
legend yeah he would want his soul he'd
want his essence yeah in the building
it's and it's there that's a real quirky
quirky house yeah
what what makes you say it's there like
what do you get out of it
um
i mean all the all the cabinets are like
handmade and they're like odd shapes and
there's like doors to nowhere and
strange like
car doors and tunnels and
really odd odd paintings on the wall and
um yeah did you ever live in it it's
very quirky
i did live in it briefly yeah
but why do you buy houses like if you
own all these houses do you just get
bored and go i think i'd like to have
that
well i
you know had one house and then
the
junior wilder house right across the
road from me
from from my main house and
it was going to get it was going to get
sold and then torn down and turned into
you know be a big construction zone for
three years and
i was like well i think i'll i'll buy it
and
preserve
the spurt of gene water and
not have a giant construction zone and
then
the
you know this i started having like some
privacy issues where like people would
like less people just like come to my
house
and
you know
start climbing over the walls and stuff
i feel like man
um
so
then i saw like what a house some of the
houses around my house and then i
thought at one point well
you know it'd be cool to to build a
house so
then i
acquired some properties at the top of
samara road uh and which is
got a great view and it's like okay well
these
some bunch of sort of small older houses
they're going to get torn down anyway i
was like well you know if i collect
these like little little houses then i
can
build something
you know i don't know artistic like a
you know
dream house type of thing what's a dream
house for elon musk like some tony stark
type [ __ ] yeah definitely
yeah you gotta have the the dome that
opens up with the stealth helicopter and
that kind of thing you know yeah for
sure [ __ ] yeah yeah
um but but then i was like man
do i really want does it really make
sense for me to spend time
designing and building a house and i'd
be real
you know
get out like ocd on the little details
and the design and
or should i be allocating that time to
getting us to mars i should probably do
the latter
so
you know like what's more important mars
or a house i like mars okay
is that really how you think like that
it'd be better off
planning on a trip to mars or getting
people to mars
yeah yeah definitely i mean
you can only do so many things right
right so how you can i don't know how
you do what you do anyway i don't i
don't understand how you can run bull
with a boring company tesla
spacex all these different things you're
doing constantly i just i don't
understand i mean you explained last
time you were here how you sort of
allocate your time and and how hectic it
is and insane i still don't the the
productivity
is uh baffling just doesn't make sense
how you can get so much done
well i think i do have high productivity
but even with that there's still some
upgraded cost of time and
allocating time to
building a house even if it was a really
great house
it still is not a good use of time
relative to
developing the rockets necessary to get
us to mars and helping sell sustainable
energy
uh
spacex and tesla are by far
you know by the the
most amount of like brain cycles
um
you know boring company does not take
you know like
less than one percent of brain cycles
and um
and then this neural link which is
i don't know maybe it's like five
percent
and then five percent that's that's a
good chunk it's a good chunk yeah yeah
we were talking about that last time and
you were
trying to figure out when it was
actually going to go live when it's
actually going to be available
are you testing on people right now
no we're not testing people yet but i i
think it won't be too long i think we
may be able to
implant a neurolink in
less than a year
in a person i think
and when you do this is there any tests
that you have to do before you do
something like this to to see what
percentage of people's bodies are going
to reject these things
is it put is it there is there a
potential for rejection
it's a very low potential for rejection
i mean you can think of it like
people put in
you know heart monitors and um
you know things for epileptic seizures
and deep brain stimulation
um obviously like you know artificial
hips and right knees and that kind of
thing so the probability of i mean like
it's so it's well known like what will
cause rejection what what will not um
it's definitely harder when you've got
something that is
sort of
reading and writing neurons that's
that's generating a current pulse and
reading current pulses that's that's a
little harder
um
then then say uh passive device but it's
still you know very doable and um yeah
there there are people who have
primitive devices in in their brains
right now
what kind of devices i like deep brain
stimulation is i think for parkinson's
is
like has
really changed people's lives in a big
way
um
which is kind of remarkable because it
kind of like
zaps your brain um it's like kicking the
tv type of thing
um and you think like man kicking the tv
shouldn't work it does sometimes yeah
yeah the old old tvs it did my grandpa
used to slap the top for sure
yeah it would work sometimes yeah so
this deep right simulation uh implanted
devices in the brain that uh
have changed people's lives for the
better like fundamentally well let's
talk about what you can talk about to
what neurolink is because the last time
you were here you really couldn't
discuss it and then there was a i guess
a press release or something that sort
of outlined yeah that that happened
quite a bit after the last time you were
here so what exactly
is it how do you do what what happens if
someone
ultimately does get a neurolink
installed what will take place
well for version one of the device it
would be
it basically implanted in your skull
so but it would be
flush with your skull so you basically
uh take out a chunk of skull replace put
the neurologic device in there
um
you put the
the electrode you'd insert the electrode
threads very carefully into the the
brain
and
uh and then you
you know
stitch it up and um and you wouldn't
even know that somebody has it
and then and and so then it it can
interface basically anywhere
in any anywhere in your brain um so it
could be something that uh you know
helps cure say uh eyesight like give you
returns your eyesight even if you've
like lost your optic nerve type of thing
uh really yeah yeah absolutely hearing
obviously um
i mean pretty much anything that where
that it could in principle fix almost
anything that is wrong with the brain
and it could
restore uh
limb functionality so if you've got uh
interface into the motor cortex and then
an implant that's say
that's like a microcontroller
and near muscle groups uh you you could
then create a
sort of a neural shunt that restores
somebody who's a quadriplegic to full
functionality
like they can walk around be normal
whoa yeah so maybe slightly better
slightly better over time yes you mean
with future iterations like the you know
six million dollar man although these
days that would that doesn't matter
yeah
six billion dollars
so the
the hole would be small how big would
the hole be that you have to drill and
then replace with this piece
it's only one hole
well
um
yeah the device we're working on right
now is about
it's about an inch in diameter
um and your skull is pretty thick by the
way so skulls are mine is for sure it
might actually literally
um i mean if you're a big if you're a
big guy your skull is actually
fairly thick um
skulls like it's like seven to 14
millimeters
um so that's probably a couple inches a
half inch you know half inch thick skull
ish
so
um yeah yeah so that's a fair bit of
like our
we got quite a coconut going on here
it's not it's not like some egg shell oh
yeah i believe you um so the
yeah you basically
implant the device uh and so you would
be like a one inch square
one inch in diameter yeah like so an
inch circle like a circular yeah i think
like a like a smart watch or something
like that
okay
yeah
okay so you take this one-inch diameter
like ice fishing right you ever go ice
fishing um no but i'd like to it's great
yeah it's really fun so you basically
take an auger and you
you drill through the surface of the ice
yeah and you create a small hole and you
can dunk your line in there so this is
like that you're ice fishing on the top
of your skull and then you cork it
yeah and you replace that
say one inch diameter piece of skull
with this neural link device
and that has a battery and a and a
bluetooth and a inductive charger um and
then you
and and now then you also got to insert
the electrodes uh so the electrode is
very carefully inserted uh with our
with a robot that we developed uh that's
you know very carefully putting in the
electrodes and avoiding you know and any
veins or arteries uh so it's
you know doesn't create trauma so
through this one-inch diameter
device electrodes be inserted and they
will find their way like tiny wires
basically tiny wires
and they'll find their way to specific
areas of the brain to stimulate no you
literally put them where they're
supposed to go oh
okay yeah
how long will these wires be
uh i mean they usually go in like you
know
depending on where it is like
you know two or three millimeters
so they just find the spots yeah
wow um and then um
yeah then
you put the device in and
that that gets uh that that replaces the
little piece of skull that was taken out
uh and then you
you stitch up the hole and and um and
you just have it look like a little scar
and that's it well this would be
replaceable or reversible yes like if
someone can't take it anymore i'm too
smart i can't take it yeah you can
totally check it out and what is the
besides
restoring limb function and eyesight and
hearing which are all amazing is there
are there any cognitive benefits that
you anticipate from something like this
uh yeah i mean you could for sure um
uh
i mean basically
it's a
generalized um
sort of
uh
thing for for fixing any kind of brain
injury in in principle like if you or if
you've got like like severe epilepsy or
something like that it could it could
just it could just sort of stop the
epilepsy from occurring like it could
detect it in real time and then fire a
counter pulse and stop the epilepsy um
if um
i mean there's a whole range of brain
injuries like if somebody gets a stroke
they could lose the ability to speak
um you know that that'll stack could
also be fixed so if you've got like
stroke damage or if you lose say
you know muscle control over part of
your face or something like that i think
and then when when you get old you tend
to
if you get like you know alzheimer's or
something like that then you lose memory
and this could help you with
you know restoring your memory that kind
of thing
restoring memory and what what is
happening that's allowing it to do that
like the wires these small wires
stimulating these areas of the brain and
then is it that the areas of the brain
are they're they're losing some sort of
electrical force like what it what is
happening yeah
yeah it's it's like it's like i think
it's like a bunch of circuits and
there's some
like circuits that are broken and we can
like
uh
fix those circuits
substitute for those circuit circuits
and so a specific frequency will go
through this yeah specific in that
would
is the process figuring out how much or
how little has to be how how much
these areas of the brain have to be
juiced up
yeah i mean there's still a lot of work
to do so when i say
you know we got a shot at probably
putting it in in a person in
you know a within a year i think that's
that's what that's exactly what i mean i
think we have a chance of putting input
into one and having them
having them
be healthy and
and restoring some functionality that
they've lost the fear is that eventually
you're gonna have to cut the whole top
of someone's head off and put a new top
with a whole bunch of wires if you want
to get
you know the real turbocharged
version
the p100d
of brain stimulation
i mean ultimately if you if you want to
go with full ai symbiosis
you'll probably
want to do something like that symbiosis
is a scary word when it comes to ai
it's optional
[Laughter]
i would hope so yeah it's just i mean
once you enjoy the dr manhattan
lifestyle once you once you become a god
seems
very
very unlikely you're going to want to go
back to being stupid again
i mean you you literally could
fundamentally change the way human
beings interface with each other
yes
yes
you wouldn't need to talk
i'm so scared of that but so excited
about it at the same time is that weird
yeah i mean
the i think this is one of the paths to
um
you know i think like what
like ai is getting better and better um
so
now let's assume it's sort of like a
benign ai scenario
even in a benign scenario we're kind of
left behind
you know we're we're not we're not along
for the ride
um we're just too dumb
right
so so how do you go along for the ride
um
yeah so you can't beat them join them so
um and we're already we're already a
cyborg to some degree right because
you've got your phone you've got your
laptop glasses yeah yeah guitar
electronic devices
and
i mean today if you your phone if you if
you don't bring your phone along it's
like you have missing limb syndrome
that's like you know it feels like
something's really really missing so
we're already
partly
um
part you know partly a cyborg um or an
ai symbiote essentially
um
it's just that the data rate to the
electronics is slow
so
especially output like you're just going
with your thumbs
i don't know like
what's your data rate maybe
optimistically 100 bits per second
that's being generous
um
and now the computer can
communicate at like you know 100
terabits
you know
so
so certainly you know
gigabits are a trivial at this point
so this this is like
you know basically
your computer could do a mil do things a
million
times faster or
at a certain point it's like talk they
as like talking to a tree
okay it's boring
you talk to a tree
it's very not very entertaining
um so
um
so if you if you can
solve the the data rate
issue and your especially output but
input two then
you can
improve the
symbiosis that is already occurring
between
mana machine
so you you can improve it
in what when you said you won't have to
talk to each other anymore we used to
joke around about that i i've joked
around about that a million times in
this podcast that one day in the future
there's going to come a time where you
can read each other's minds and well
you'll be able to interface with each
other in some sort of a non-verbal
non-physical way where you will transfer
data back and forth to each other
without having to actually use your
mouth
and make noises
exactly so when you
like what happens when you when like
let's say you've got some complex idea
that you're trying to convey to somebody
else and how do you do that
well your brain spends a lot of effort
compressing
a complex concept
into words
and there's a there's a lot a lot of
loss
information loss that occurs when
compressing a complex concept into words
and then you say those words those words
are then interpreted then they're
decompressed by the person who is
listening
and they they will at best get a very
incomplete understanding of what you're
trying to convey it's very difficult to
convey a complex concept with precision
because you've got
compression
decompression
you may not even have heard all the
words correctly
and so
communication is difficult you know what
we have here is a failure to communicate
cool and luke yes and there's a great
movie yeah
there's an interpretation factor too
like you can
choose to interpret
certain series of words in in different
ways and they're dependent upon tone
dependent upon social cues
even facial expressions sarcasm there's
a lot of variables sarcasm is difficult
yes yeah and so
one of the things that
i i've said is like that there could be
potentially a universal language that's
created through computers that
particularly young kids would pick up
very quickly like my kids do tick tock
and all this jazz and i don't know what
they're doing they just know how to do
it and they know how to do it really
quickly like they learn really quickly
they show me how to edit things and yeah
it's if you taught a child from first
grade on how to use some new universal
language i mean essentially like a
rosetta stone
and
something that's done
that interprets
your thoughts and you can convey your
thoughts with no room for interpretation
with clear very clear that where you
know what a person's saying and you can
tell them
what you're saying and there's no need
for noises no need for mouth noises no
need for
these sort of accepted ways that we've
uh sort of evolved to make sounds that
we all agree
we through our cultural dictionary right
we agree or certainly we could bypass
all that yeah we can still do it for for
sentimental reasons right
like campfires
yeah yeah exactly i don't need campfires
i don't need to roast marshmallows kind
of fun right um
so yeah um
yeah i think you would in principle you
would be able to communicate
very quickly
and
with far
more precision
ideas
and
language would
i'm not sure what would happen to
language but you could probably within a
situation like this that you would be
able to just kind of like the matrix you
you want to speak a different language
in a problem right that's why it just
downloaded the program
right so
at least for the first iterations first
few iterations we'll just be able to use
like i i know that google has uh their
some of their pixel buds have the
ability to interpret languages in real
time
sure yeah you can hear it and they'll
it'll play things back to you in
whatever language you choose so to be
something along those lines
yeah for the first few iterations
well the first few iterations are i mean
what i'm talking about is like in the
limit over time you know with a lot of
development um the first few iterations
really in the first
few versions all we're going to be
trying to do is solve brain injuries um
so so it's like don't don't worry that
that's not going to sneak up on you
this this will take a while how many
years
before you don't have to talk
if the if the development
continues to accelerate then
maybe
like five years
five to ten years that's quick
that's really quick that's the best case
scenario no talking anymore in five
years best case scenario
but i'm 10 10 years more like it
i've always speculated that aliens could
potentially be us in the future because
if you look at like the size their heads
and the fact that they have very little
muscle and then they don't use their
mouth anymore they was tiny little i
mean the archetypal alien that you see
in like closing counters are the third
kind they they're like if you went from
like uh
australopithecus or ancient hominid to
us what's the difference less hair less
muscle bigger head
and then just keep going a thousand a
million whatever you or five years
whatever whatever happens when neurolink
goes on online and then we slowly start
to adapt to this new way of being
where we don't use our muscles anymore
we have this gigantic head we can talk
without words
you could also
save state
and save state save state like save your
brain state like like a saved game in a
video game whoa
like like if you want to swap from
windows 95
well
yeah i think we are windows 95 right now
yeah
from a future perspective probably um
but yeah i mean you you could
save state
um
and restore that state into a biological
being if you if you wanted to in the
future in principle it's like nothing
like from a physics standpoint that
prevents us now you'd be a little
different but then you're also a little
different when you wake up in the
morning from yesterday and you're a
little different in fact if you say like
you five years ago versus you today is
quite a big difference yes um so
you'd be substantially you i mean you'd
be you'd certainly think you're you but
the idea of saving yourself and then
transforming that into some sort of a
biological state like you can hang out
with 30 year old you
i mean the possibilities are endless
that's so weird i mean these things
think like how your phone can you can
record videos on your phone like there's
no way you could remember a video right
as accurately as your phone or a camera
you know could
so
uh
now if you've got like a you know some
some
you know version 10 hero link whatever
and far in the future
you could
you could remember you could
recall everything but just like it's a
movie
concluding all the entire sensory
experience emotions everything
everything everything
and play it back
and you can enjoy it you should edit it
edit it yeah so you can change your past
you could change what do you think was
your past yeah well so if you had like a
tremendous thing right now
could be a replayed memory it could be
yeah it may be
what's the odds of this being a replayed
memory if you had a guess
it's more than 50
there's no way to assign a probability
with accuracy here right but roughly
if you just had a just gut instinct
well i don't have a neural link in my
brain so i say right now zero percent
but at the point at which you do have a
neural link then it rises above zero
percent
the idea that we're experiencing some
sort of a preserved memory
is uh
even though it's still the same it's not
comforting
right for some reason when we people
talk about
simulation theory they talk about the
potential for this currently being a
simulation it even though your life
might be wonderful you might be in love
you might love your career you might
have great friends
but it's not comforting to know that
this experience somehow or another
doesn't exist in a material form that
you can knock
on it feels real doesn't it feels real
but but if it's not but the idea that
it's not is for some strange reason
disconcerting well yeah i'm sure it
should be disconcerting
because then if this is not real what is
right um but but the you know there's
that that old sort of um
thought experiment of like
how do you know you're not a brain in a
vet
you know i mean now here's the thing you
are a brain an event then that fat is
your skull yes and everything you see
feel here
everything all your senses are
electrical signals everything
everything
is an electrical signal to up to a brain
in a vat where the vat is called and all
your hormones all your neurotransmitters
all these things are drugs adrenaline's
a drug dopamine's a drug you're a drug
factory
you're constantly changing your state
with love and oxytocin and
and beauty sure changes your state great
music changes your state absolutely
and yet here's another
sort of interesting idea which is um
because you say like where did
consciousness arise well assuming you
believe
the
belief in physics which appears to be
true um
then you know we the universe started
off as basically quarks and leptons and
it quickly became hydrogen
and of helium lithium like basically
elements the periodic table
but it was like mostly hydrogen
basically
and then
and then over a long period of time
uh
you know 13.8 billion years later
that hydrogen became sentient
but
so where
along the way
that conju where is the consciousness
what's the line of consciousness and not
consciousness right between hydrogen and
here
right when do we call it when do we call
it consciousness i was watching a video
today that we played on a podcast
earlier of a monkey riding a motorcycle
down the street jumps off the motorcycle
and tries to steal a baby yeah i saw
that one they went apparel what is that
monkey conscious it seems like it is it
seems like it had a plan it was riding a
[ __ ] motorcycle and then jumped off
the motorcycle to try to steal a baby
seems pretty the one that just strike
baby down the street pretty far yeah
yeah
seems pretty conscious
right
there's definitely some degree of
consciousness there yeah it's not like
it's not a worm it seems to be on
another level
yeah and it's going to keep going and
that that's the real concern
when when people think about the
potential future versions of human
beings especially when you consider
symbiotic relationship to artificial
intelligence it will be unrecognizable
that one day we'll be so far removed
from what this is we'll look back on
this
the way we look back now on you know
simple
simple organisms that we evolved from
and then it won't be that far in the
future that we do have this this view
back
well i hope consciousness propagates
into the future and it gets more
more sophisticated and complex and
and that it understands the
questions to ask about the universe
do you think that's the case
as a human being as yourself you're
clearly
trying to make conscious decisions to be
a better version of you right this is
the idea of like getting rid of your
possessions and realizing that you're
trying to like i don't like this i will
try to improve this i will try to do a
better version of the way i interface
with reality
that this is always the way things are
if you're if you're moving in a
some sort of a direction where you're
trying to improve things you're always
going to move
into this new place where you look back
in the old place and go i was doing it
wrong back then
so this is an accelerated version of
that
super accelerated version of that
i mean
you don't always improve but you can
aspire to improve
you can aspire to be less wrong yeah
this is like i think a good the tools of
physics are very powerful like just
assume you're wrong and you're asking
your goals to be less wrong
i don't think you're gonna if you
succeed every day and being less wrong
but you know
if you're gonna succeed in being less
wrong
most of the time you're doing great
that's a great way of putting aspire to
be less wrong
but then when you know people look back
at nostalgia about simpler times there's
that too it's very romantic and exciting
to look back on
campfires
but you can still have a campfire yes
yeah but will you appreciate it when
you're a super nerd when you're
connected to the grid and you have some
uh skull cap in place of the top of your
head and it's interfacing with the inter
international language
that the rest of the universe now enjoys
communication with people
and we're yeah
sure i think so
yeah i like empires
[Laughter]
i'm just worried i mean uh everyone's
always scared of change but i'm scared
of this monumental change where we won't
we won't talk anymore
i mean that thing will communicate yes
but that's
there's something about
there's something about the beauty of
the crudeness of language
where when it's done eloquently it's
it's it's satisfying and
it it it
hits us in some sort of a visceral way
like ah that person nailed it i love
that they nailed it like that it's so
hard to capture
a real thought and convey it in a way
in this articulate way that makes
someone except like you read a quote a
great quote by a wise person it makes
you excited that their mind
figured something out put the words
together in a right way that makes your
brain pop like oh yes
yeah yes
it's clever compression of a concept
yeah and a feeling
but the fact that a human did it too
yeah absolutely do you think that it'll
be like electronic music like people
won't appreciate it like they appreciate
a slide guitar
i like electronic music i do too yeah
well you make it i know you liked it
yeah
yeah yeah um
yeah i mean i hope the future is more
fun and interesting and we should try to
make that way
i hope it's more fun and interesting too
yeah
i just
you know i just hope you don't lose
anything along the way
yeah we might at least little but
hopefully we'll gain more than lose yeah
that's the thing right gaining more than
we lose like something that makes us
interesting is that we're so flawed it's
not for sure right yeah
i mean you look at civilizations through
the ages um
most of them uh you know they rose and
fell yeah and uh
i do think like the
globalization
uh that that we have
at the sort of like the the meme sphere
uh is uh
there's not enough isolation between
countries
or regions
um
it's like if you get up if there's a
mind virus
that that my virus cannot infect too
much of the world
uh you know like i actually
sort of sympathize with the
anti-globalization people because it's
it's like man we don't ever want
everywhere to be the same for sure and
then we we need some kind of like mind
viral immunity
so
that that's it's a bit concerning mind
viral immunity meaning that once
something like neural link gets
established the real concern is
something that i mean you said it's
bluetooth right or some future version
of that that the idea is that something
could possibly get into it [ __ ] it up no
i'm talking about like uh somebody
there's some cockeyed concept that um
that's happened that happens right right
now
yeah
well i know there's viruses and embedded
chips right like people have
they've embedded chips and then acquired
viruses well when i'm talking about my
verse i'm talking about like a a concept
that affects people's minds
oh okay okay
like uh
cult thinking or yeah some sort of
fundamentalism yeah just
wrong-headed idea that yes goes
viral in a
in an idea sense
[Music]
well that is that is a problem too right
if someone can manipulate that
technology to make something appear
logical or rational
yeah yeah that would that be an issue
too with
this is a very have versus have not
issue right once this thing if if this
really does
i mean initially it's going to help
people with with injuries and but you
you said
ultimately it could lead to this
spectacular cognitive change yes but the
people that first get it
should have a massive advantage
over people that don't have it yet
well i mean it's the kind of thing where
your productivity would improve
i don't know dramatically maybe by a
factor of 10 with it so
you could definitely just
you know uh i don't know take out a loan
and do it and earn earn the money back
real fast
so you're super smart
well
in a capitalist society
you know you could it seems like you
could really get so far ahead that
before everybody else could afford this
thing and link up and get connected as
well you'd be so far ahead they could
never catch you
is that a concern uh
well
i think the the
it's not a super huge concern i mean
there are huge differences in cognitive
ability and and resources already yeah
um
i mean you can think of a corporation as
like a
cybernetic collective
uh that's
far smarter than an individual like i i
can personally build like a whole rocket
and and the engines and launch it and
everything that's impossible uh but
you know we have eight thousand people
with spacex and
you
might
you know piecing it out to different
people
um
and using like you know computers and
machines and stuff we can make
lots of rockets launch and all but
stuck with the space station that kind
of thing you know um so
that already exists where this
you know where there's a
corporations are vastly more capable
than an individual
um
but the the
like we should be i think less concerned
about like relative
capabilities between people and and more
like
uh
having ai be vastly
you know beyond us and
decoupled from human will
decoupled from human so this is the if
you can't beat them join them
yeah i mean so you feel like it's
inevitable like ai sentient ai is
essentially inevitable super sentient ai
yeah
like beyond a level that's difficult to
understand
and impossible to understand probably
and somehow or another
us
so it's almost like
it's a
requirement for survival to
achieve some sort of symbiotic existence
with ai
it's not a requirement it's
just um
if you if you want to be along for the
ride
then you need to do some kind of
symbiosis so the the way your brain
works right now you've got uh
kind of like the animal brain reptile
brain kind of let's
say
it's like the limbic system basically
and you've got the the cortex
um
now the brain purists will argue with
this definition but essentially you've
got
the primitive brain and you've got the
the sort of
smart brain or the brain that's capable
of planning and understanding concepts
and different difficult you know things
that a monkey can't understand um
now the
your cortex is much much smarter than
your olympic system
um
nonetheless they work together well
so i haven't met anyone who wants to
delete the olympic system or the cortex
that people are quite happy having both
um
so you can think of the
this as being
like the computer the ai is like a
a third layer a tertiary layer
so that is
like that could be symbiotic with the
cortex it'd be much smarter than the
cortex but you'd essentially have three
layers
and you actually have that right now
your phone is capable of things and your
computer is capable things that your
brain is definitely not
you know storing
your terabytes of information
perfectly
um
doing
incredible calculations that you you
know we couldn't even come close to
doing
you have that with your computer
it's just like i said the data rate is
slow the connection is weak
why is it so
disconcerting or why is it why does it
not give me comfort
to think about like when i think about a
symbiotic connection to ai i always
think of this cold
emotionless
sort of
thing that we will become
is that a bad way to look at it i don't
think that's not that's not quite that's
not how it would be
like i said you you already are yeah
symbiotic with ai or computers phones
computers laptops yeah and there's
there's quite a bit of ai going on you
know near so artificial neural nets
um increasingly
neural nets are
sort of taking over from regular
programming more and more
so
you are connected
um
you know
if you use
google voice or alexa or one of those
things it's using a neural net to decode
your speech and try to understand what
you're saying
um
you know if if you're trying to image
recognition or improve the quality of
photograph it's
it's using the neural nets the best way
to do that so
um you are already
uh
sort of a
sort of a cybernetic symbiote
it like said you
when that
it's just a question of your data rate
the the the communication speed between
your your phone and your brain is slow
when do you think you're gonna do it
how long will you wait um
like once it starts becoming available
yeah if it works i'll do it sure
right away
i mean let's make sure it works
how do we make sure it works we're
trying on prisoners like what do you do
no no you take rapists no cut holes in
your head
now like i said if somebody's got a
serious brain injury right um
and though you know people have like
very severe brain injuries um
and then and then you can fix those
those brain injuries um and
you know then you prove out that it
works and you expand envelope expand and
make more and more brain injuries
uh sold more and more um and that you
know suddenly at certain age we all are
are going to get alzheimer's we're all
going to get senile um and then you know
moms forget the names of their kids and
that kind of thing and so
you know
it's like you said okay well you know
this would allow you to
remember your names your kids and and
and have
a normal a much more normal life where
you you you're able to function much
later in life
um so i think that so essentially that
there would almost everyone would find a
need at some point if if you get old
enough to
use your neural link
and
and and then it's like okay so we can
improve the functionality and improve
the communications communication speed
so
then you
will not have to use your thumbs to
communicate with the computer
do you ever sit down extrapolate do you
ever like sit down and think about
all the different iterations of this and
what this eventually leads to
um yeah i mean i think sure think about
a lot um
there's
like i said this is not something that's
going to sneak up on you you know
there's like getting fda approval for
this stuff is not like overnight you
know um
and
this there's
i mean we probably
have to be on like version 10 or
something
before
you know
it it
would realistically be
um
you know a human ai symbiote situation
so you'll see it coming you know
you see it coming but what do you think
it's going to be
like when you sit when you're alone if
you have free time i don't know if you
have free time but if you just sit down
and think
about
this iteration the next onward keep
going
and you you drag it out with
improvements along the way
and leaps and bounds and technological
innovations and
where do you see it
what are we going to be like when 20 25
years from now what are we going to be
well assuming civilization is still
around um it's looking fragile right now
um
i think we i think we could have a
in 25 years probably something i think
like that could be a whole brain
interface
a whole brain interface
sorry pretty close to that yeah how does
how do you define what do you mean by
whole brain interface
um
like almost all the neurons
are connected to
uh
you're the sort of
ai extension of yourself
if you want ai extension of yourself
yeah
what does that mean to you like when you
say ai extension of yourself
well you like i said you already have
a computer extension of yourself in your
phone
you know and computers and stuff so and
now online it's like somebody dies
there's this like an online ghost
that they're they're still their online
stuff yeah it's alive that's a good way
to put it it is weird when you read
someone's tweets after they're dead
yeah yeah
instagram and their stories and stuff
yeah whatever facebook inside you know
like that's a great way to put it it's
like an online ghost
that's very accurate
yeah so
yeah so there's
it would just be that that more of you
would be
in the cloud i guess than in your body
more of it more of you
whoa
now when you say civilization's fragile
do you mean because of this covet 19
[ __ ] that's going on right now what's
that i've never heard of it it's this
thing yeah no it's like uh some people
just get a card other people
it gets much worse
uh sure
yeah
well
yeah
i mean this certainly has taken over the
mayan space of the world
to a degree that is quite shocking yeah
well out of nowhere that's what's crazy
it's like
you go back to november nothing now here
we are december january february march
april may six months
totally different world
so from nothing to everything's locked
down
there's so much uh conflicting
information and conflicting opinions
about how to proceed
what what has happened
you you find things where
there was a meat packing plant i believe
in missouri where
300 plus people were asymptomatic tested
positive or asymptomatic and then in
other places it just ravages entire
communities and kills people and it's
it's so weird it almost appears on the
out like if you didn't know any better
you'd be like what it seems like there's
a bunch of different viruses it doesn't
seem like it's the same thing or has a
bunch of different reactions to the
biological variety of of people
yeah um
i mean i kind of saw this whole thing
play out in china uh before it played
out in the us
so
um it's kind of like watching the same
movie again
but in english
um so
yeah um
i might i think the the the the
mortality rate is much less than what is
then what say the world health
organization said it was it's very much
module assets like probably at least
order of magnitude less well it seems to
be very deadly to very specific kinds of
people and people with specific problems
yeah i mean if you're
you can look at the mortality statistics
you know by age and whether they have
comorbid comorbidities like do they have
like basically existing conditions and
um by age um and uh
you know if you're
below 60 and and have no serious health
issues the probability of death is
extremely low it's not zero but it's
extremely low
they didn't think that this was the case
though when they first started to lock
down the country do you think that it's
a situation where once they've proceeded
in a certain way it's very difficult to
correct course
it's almost like people really wanted
a panic
that you know
quite quite crazy
but in some places a panic is deserved
right like if you're in the icu in
manhattan and people are dying left and
right and everyone's on intubators and
it's
it's it seems like
when you see all these people on
ventilators and so many of them are
dying and you see these nurses are dying
and doctors are getting sick
in some places
that
fear is justified but then in other
places
you're reading these stories about
hospitals that are
essentially half empty
they're they're having to furlough
doctors and nurses because there's no
work for them
most of the hospitals in the united
states right now half empty
in some cases they're at 30 capacity
and is this because they've decided to
forego elective procedures
and and normal things that people would
have to go to the hospital for
yes i mean
we're not talking about just
some of these elective procedures are
quite important like it's like you have
about a lot of disease yeah sure and you
need a you know triple bypass it's like
sort of elective but if you don't get it
done in time it's you're gonna die yeah
it's elective is a weird word yeah
elective it's not like hey i i want to
it's not like plastic surgery
it's more like like my my hip is i'm in
extreme pain because my my hips blown
out or my knee and i
don't want to go to the hospital i can't
go to the hospital to you know people in
extreme pain
people that need a kidney you know like
people that have like quite serious
issues that are choosing not to go out
of fear um so i think it's
it's a problem it's not good it seems
like the state of public perception is
shifting it is like people are taking
some deep breaths and relaxing and
because of the statistics of i mean and
essentially across the board it's being
recognized that it's not
as fatal as we thought it was still
dangerous still worse than the flu but
not as bad
as we thought or we feared it could be
i mean objectively the mortality is is
much lower
like
at least a factor of 10
maybe a factor of 50 lower than
initially thought
do you think that the current way we're
handling this
the social distancing the mass the
locking down is it does this make sense
is it adequate or do you think that we
should
move back to
at least closer to where we used to be
well i think proper hygiene is a good
thing no matter what you know wash your
hands and
you know and if you're
if you're coughing stay home or wear a
mask this is not good you know um like
they do that in japan that's like normal
if you're if you're ill you you wear a
face mask and you don't cough on people
i think that that would be a great thing
to to adopt in general throughout the
world
um
washing your hands is
also good well that's the speculation
why men get it more than women because
men are disgusting and we don't watch
that disgusting it's true it's true yeah
we're all my men in this room we're all
gross yeah let's go to the restroom you
can see us yes we're gross my daughter
my nine-year-old daughter yells at me
she goes did you wash your hands she
makes me go back and wash my hands hmm
she's right
nine years old if i had a nine-year-old
boy do you think he would care i
wouldn't give a [ __ ] if i wash my hands
true
um
so yeah i think that there's definitely
some silver linings here
than in improved uh
you know uh hygiene yeah and an
awareness of potential yes and i think
this has shaken up the the system uh
system is like somewhat more bond with
la la's layers of bureaucracy and i
think that we've cut through some of
that bureaucracy
uh and
if we you know at some point there
probably will be a
uh
pandemic with with a with a high
mortality rate uh
debate about like what's high but i mean
like someone that's killing a lot of 20
year olds let's say like it's
yeah if you had like ebola type of
mortality spanish flu something that uh
tax immune systems of healthy people
yeah yeah um yeah but it's a
yeah like like killing large numbers of
young healthy people that that's
you know
define that as like uh
uh
high mortality then that this is at
least practice for something like that
um and i think there's
this you know
given it's just a matter of time that
there will be eventually some
some such pandemic
do you think that in a sense the one
good thing that we might get out of this
is the realization that this is a
potential reality that we we got lucky
in this sense i mean in people that
didn't get lucky and died of course i'm
not disrespecting their death and their
loss but i'm saying overall as a as a
culture as a community as a human race
as a community
this is not as bad as it could have been
this is a good dry run for us to
appreciate
that we need far more resources
dedicated towards the the understanding
these diseases
what to do in the case of pandemic and
much more
money that goes to funding
treatments and and some preventative
measures
yeah absolutely um
and i think i think there's a
good chance it's highly likely i think
coming out of this that
we will develop uh vaccines that we
didn't have before
uh for uh
quran viruses and other other viruses um
and and possibly cures uh for for these
and our understanding of
uh viruses of this nature has improved
dramatically because of the attention
that it's received
so
there's definitely some you know a lot
of silver linings here um
and potentially if we act correctly
yeah yeah yeah there's uh i think
there will be some amounts of lighting
here no matter what um hopefully it can
be more professive lighting than less
yeah
um
so yeah this is this is uh
it's like kind of like a practice run
for something that had that that had a
potential that might in the future have
a serious uh like a really high
mortality rate that
and we
kind of got to go through this with
without without it being something that
kills you know vast numbers of
young healthy people
yeah
when you made a series of tweets
recently uh you know uh i don't remember
the exact wording but essentially you
were saying free america now like let's
think about that is it thank you
but uh the the you know what was the
how much do you pay attention to the
response to that stuff and what was the
response like
did anybody go hey elon what the [ __ ]
you doing did anybody pull you aside
who does that who gets to do that to you
well i mean i certainly get that there's
no shortage of negative feedback on
twitter you know oh yeah twitter
yeah but i don't read that do you read
it warzone you do sometimes though right
you do read it yeah i mean
scroll through the comments like as a
meme warzone
yeah i mean people knife you're good
it's something i i enjoy about
that just the
there's a
something about the
the freedom of expression that comes
from all these people that do attack you
it's like well they if there was no
vulnerability whatsoever they wouldn't
attack you and
it's like there's something about these
millions and millions of perspectives
that you you have to
you have to appreciate
even if it comes your way even if the
[ __ ] storm hits you in the face sure you
gotta appreciate wow how amazing is it
that all these people do have the
ability to express themselves
you don't don't necessarily want to be
there when the [ __ ] hits you sure you
might want to get out of the way in
anticipation of the [ __ ] storm but the
fact that so many people have the
ability to reach out and i think it's in
a lot of ways it's uh i don't wanna say
a misused resource but it's like giving
monkeys guns they just start
they start gunning down
things that in front of them without any
realization of what they're doing they
have a rock they see a window they throw
it whoa look at that i got elon madd
look at that this guy got mad at me this
this i i [ __ ] took this person down
on twitter i got this lady fired oh the
[ __ ] business is going under because
of twitter wars it seems like there's
something about it that's this
newfound
thing
that uh i want to say abuse but just i
want to say that it's almost like you
know you hit the button and things blow
up you're like wow
this is what else can we blow up
sure
um
i mean i've been in the twitter war zone
for for a while here so put your war
zone
you know take it takes a lot to phase me
at this point yeah that's good too right
like you develop a thick skin
yeah you can't take it personally these
people don't like actually know you you
know like yeah
it's just like
you know so it's like if you're if
you're fighting a war
and there's like some opposing soldier
that that shoots shoots at you it's not
like they hate you they don't even know
you right yeah yeah so
just think of it like that like they're
firing bullets or whatever um but they
don't know you so don't take it
personally there's something interesting
about it too it's like uh like when you
write something in you know 280
characters and they write something into
it it's such a crude way
it's like you know someone's saying
sending opposing smoke signals that
refute your smoke signals it's like
it's so crude
and especially when you're talking about
something like neural link he's talking
about some future potential where you're
going to be able to express pure
thoughts that get get conveyed through
some sort of a universal language with
no ambiguity whatsoever
versus
you know tweets
well there'll always be some ambiguity
but yeah
tweets are
it's hard um
like the maybe there should be like a
sarcasm flag or something you know right
right um or i'm not you know just
kidding or whatever you know like don't
you know it seems like it would take
away some of the fun from people that
know it's sarcasm like if everybody knew
that the onion wasn't real if you sent
people articles yeah is something about
someone getting angry at an onion
article wow that's amazing you know what
i mean where they don't realize what it
is there's something fun about that for
everybody else
uh yeah
i know it's pretty great
it might be the best news source
do you know who titania mcgrath is
hilario it's uh andrew boyle he's a uh a
british fellow a brilliant guy who's
been on the podcast before and he has
this uh fictional character this uh
pseudonym titania mcgrath who's like
this all the ultimate social justice
warrior
is this like
like a female avatar
a female avatar that's actually a
computer conglomeration of a bunch of
faces okay it's not really one person so
one person can't be a victim and be
angry he's sort of combined these faces
to make this one perfect social justice
more okay but the thing like i
recognized it early on before i met him
sure that this was parody this is this
was just fun
and then i love reading the people that
don't recognize that they get angry sure
and then they're really really like
there's a lot of people that just get
really furious sure about some of
some fun to that
there's some fun to the not picking up
on the the the true nature of the signal
i find twitter quite engaging
how do you have the time
um well i mean it's like
five minutes every couple hours type of
thing it's not like i'm sitting on an
old day but even five minutes every
couple hours if those are bad five
minutes they might be bouncing around
your head for the next 30.
yeah you have to
you know like i said
take a certain amount of
distance from you read this and you're
like okay it's bullets being fired by an
opposing army
you know don't like it
it's not like they they like so it's not
like they know you it's like
don't take it personally um did you feel
the same way when when cnn
had that stupid [ __ ] about ventilators
with you
i i found that
both confusing and the the the
yeah that was annoying it was annoying
but what is also annoying as a person
who reads
cnn and wants to think of them as a
responsible conveyor of the facts
i would like to think that
yeah
i don't think cnn is that i think he
used to be he used to be yeah
um like what do you think's the the best
source of just like information out
there that's a good question you know
like
let's say you're just like
average citizen trying to just get the
facts you know figure out what's going
on like you know how to
live your life and
you know just looking for
what what's going on in the world that
it's hard to find something that that
isn't
you know
that's that that's good yeah you know uh
that you know not not trying to push
some partisan angle not trying to not
not sort of doing sloppy reporting and
and just aiming for the most number of
clicks and trying to maximize ad dollars
and that kind of thing yeah
you're just trying to figure out what's
going on it's like
i'm hard pressed
where do you go i don't know i don't
think there's any pure form
my favorite
places are the new york times and the la
times and i don't trust them 100 percent
you know because also there's
individuals that are writing these
stories
exactly and that's seems to be the
problems these individual biases and
these individual
there's
purposely distorted perceptions and then
there's ignorantly
reported facts and there's so many
variables and you got to put everything
through this filter of where is this
person coming from do they have
political biases do they have social
biases do they are they
are they upset because of their own
shortcomings and they are they
projecting this into the story sure it's
so hard
yeah i think like maybe just trying to
find individual reporters that you think
are good and yeah kind of falling down
as opposed to the publication i go with
whatever matt taibbi says
okay i trust him more than anybody all
right
matt taib he's onto something i just
he's as far as investigative reporters
in particular the way he reported the
savings and loan crisis the way he
reports everything i just i just listen
to him above
most
above mo he's my go-to guy all right
i'll check it out uh it's rolling
stone's articles or his stuff on the
savings alone crisis just like what in
the [ __ ]
and you know and he wasn't you know he's
not an economist by any stretch of the
imagination so he had to really sort of
deeply embed himself in that world to
try to understand it and to be able to
report on it
and was also with a humorous flair
for now that's nice yeah um
yeah
but it's not that many of them there's
it's hard and not a location where like
we are no [ __ ] that's right you know
we are no bullshit.com like the one
place where you can say this is what we
know this is what we don't know this is
what we think not
this person's wrong and here's why like
oh
god damn it you know i can't you you
don't know there's a lot of stuff that
is open to interpretation
yeah
this this particular coronavirus issue
that we're dealing with right now seems
to be a great
illuminator of that very fact is that
there's so much
data and there's this so there's so much
that's open to interpret there's so many
thing because it's all happening in real
time right and like particularly right
now in california we're in stage two
tomorrow or friday two days from now
stage two retail stores opening up
things are changing like when no one
knows the correct
process that needs to take place to save
the most amount of lives but yet ensure
that our
our culture and that our
our our economy survives
it's a lot of speculation and guessing
but if you go to certain places they'll
tell you we know why and we know this
and we know uh
it's hard
yeah i mean
i
in general i think that's like we should
be concerned about
um anything that's a massive
infringement on our civil civil
liberties yes you know so it's like
you got to put a lot of weight on that
um
you know people
a lot of people died to
you know win independence with the
country and and fight for the democracy
that we have and uh
you know we should treasure that and not
and not give up our liberties too easily
i think we've we
i mean i think we probably did that
actually
well i like what you said when you said
that it should be a choice
and that
to require people to stay home require
people to not go to work require and to
to arrest people for trying to make a
living this all seems wrong and i think
it's a wrong approach it's a it's uh
you're you're
it's an infantilization
of the society
that daddy's going to tell you what to
do fundamentally a violation of the
constitution yeah freedom of assembly
and you know it's just
i mean i don't think these things stand
up in court really they're arresting
people for protesting yeah yeah because
they're protesting and violating social
distancing and these mandates that tell
people that they have to stay home
yeah these these are these would
definitely not stand up uh you know if
the
supreme court here i mean it's obviously
a complete violation right yeah yeah and
again this is not
in any way um disrespecting the people
who have died from this disease that's
certainly a real thing to think of
yeah i mean it it it just should be if
if you're if you're at risk you should
not be compelled to leave your house
right um or leave a place of safety but
you should also not be
uh if you're not at risk or if you are
at risk and you wish to take a risk with
your life you should have the right to
do that and it seems like at this point
in time particularly
our resources would be best served
protecting the people that are at risk
versus penalizing the people that are
not at high risk for living their life
the way they did particularly having a
career and and making a living and
feeding your family
paying your bills keeping your store
open keeping your restaurant open
yes
i mean there's there's a strong a strong
downside to this yeah
so
yeah i just believe like you know if
this is a free country you should be
you know a lot allowed to do
you know what you want as long as it
does not endanger others but that's the
thing right people this is the argument
they will bring up like you are
endangering others you should stay home
for the people that that
you even if you're fine even if you know
you're gonna be okay there's certain
people that will not be okay because of
your actions they might get exposed to
this thing that we don't have a vaccine
for
we don't have universally accepted
treatment for
and then we need to ca this is there's
two arguments right the one argument is
we need to keep going protect the weak
protect the sick but let's open up the
economy the other argument is stop
placing money over human lives
and let's shelter in place until we come
up with some sort of a decision and
let's figure out some way to develop
some sort of universal income universal
basic income plan or something like that
to feed people during the during this
time
when we make this transition i think
there's a
yeah um
as i said right
yeah my opinion is if if somebody wants
to stay home they should stay home and
say something doesn't want to stay home
they should not be compelled to stay
home
that's my opinion do you think
if somebody doesn't like that well
that's my opinion
um
so
the now yeah um
the the this notion though that uh you
know you can just sort of send checks
out everybody and and things will be
fine it's not true obviously um the
there's some people have this absurd
like a
view that the economy is like some magic
horn of plenty
like it it just makes stuff
stuff you know whatever it just there's
a magic quarter plenty and the goods and
services they just come from this magic
corner plenty and then if um like if
somebody has more stuff than somebody
else's because they took more from this
magic corner plenty now let me uh just
break it to uh
the fools out there
if you don't make stuff
there's no stuff
yeah
so
if you don't make the food if you don't
process the food you know transport the
food
and what the
whether you know medical treatment
getting getting your teeth fixed
there's no stuff
i become detached from reality
you can't just
legislate
money and solve these things if you
don't make stuff there is no stuff
obviously
we'll run out of the stores
run out of the you know
it's the whole the machine just grinds
to a halt
but the the initial thought on this
virus the real fear was that this was
going to kill
hundreds of thousands if not millions of
people instantaneously
in this country it was going to do it
very quickly if we didn't hunker down if
we didn't shelter in place if we didn't
quarantine ourselves or lock down
do you think that the initial thought
was a good idea based on the perception
that this was going to be far more
deadly than it turned out to be
maybe i think
briefly briefly briefly
but uh i think if you know any any kind
of like sensible examination of what
happened in china would lead to the
conclusion that that is obviously not
going to occur uh this this virus
originated in wuhan there's like i don't
know hundred thousand people a day
leaving on uh so it that that it it uh
it went everywhere very fast
through throughout china throughout the
rest of the world
um and
the fatality rate was
was low don't you think though it's
difficult to appreciate it's it's it's
difficult to filter
what the information is coming out of
china
to accurately
really get a real true representation of
what happened the the propaganda machine
is very strong sure what
the world health organization appears to
have been complicit
with a lot of their propaganda
the thing is that
american companies have massive
supply chains in china like tesla for
example we have hundreds of suppliers
like tier one two three four suppliers
throughout throughout china so
we know if they are able to make stuff
or not
we know if they if they have issues or
not
then they they're china is back back at
full steam
um and until
many
uh pretty much every u.s company has
some significant number of flies in
china so you know you know if they're
able to
you know
provide things or not or if there's
you know
high mortality rate
tesla has seven thousand people in china
so
zero people died
um zero
okay so that that's a real statistic
that's coming from yeah yeah you know
those people yeah we literally we're in
payroll do you think there's a danger of
this
same folks are there yeah
do you think there's a danger of
politicizing this whereas becomes like
opening up the country's uh donald
trump's
it's his goal it's his and then
anything he does is sort of uh there's
there's people that are going to oppose
it and come up with some reasons why
he's wrong particularly in this climate
whereas as we're leading up november
and you know the the 2020 elections do
you think that this is a real danger in
terms of uh public's perception that
trump wants to open it up so they
knee-jerk
oppose it because they oppose trump
i i think there has been some
politician this has been
politicized
you know
in both directions really so it's
um
which is
not great
yeah but like i said separate apart from
that i think there's the question of
like
you know where do several civil
liberties fit in this picture you know
yeah and uh what what what can the
government make you do what can they
make you not do and what you know what's
what's okay right um
and uh
yeah i think we went too far
do you think it's one of those things
where once
we've gone in a certain direction it's
very difficult to make a correction
make a an adjustment to to realize like
okay we thought it was one thing it's
not it's not good but it's not what we
thought it was going to be it's not what
we feared so let's let's back up and
reconsider let's do this publicly and
say we were acting
based on the information that we had
initially that information appears to be
faulty
and uh here's how we move forward while
protecting civil liberties while
protecting what essentially this country
was founded on which is a very agreed
upon amount of freedom yeah that we
respect and appreciate
absolutely
well i think we're we're rapidly moving
towards opening up the country um it's
going to happen extremely fast over the
next few weeks
so
yeah
something that would be helpful just add
from an informational level is
um when reporting uh
sort of
covet cases to separate out
diagnosed with covert versus uh had
covert like symptoms yes
because the list of symptoms that could
be covered at this point is like a mile
long so it's like a hard to
if you're ill at all it's like it could
be covered so
just just to give people better
information
definitely diagnosed with covert or
had covered like symptoms we're
conflating those two
so that one that it looks bigger than it
is
then uh if somebody dies is
was covert a a primary cause
of the death or not
uh i mean if i mean if somebody has kova
gets eaten by a shark
we find their arm their arm has covered
it's gonna get recorded as a cover death
is that real
basically not that bad but heart attacks
strokes you get hit by a bug cancer
if you if you get hit by a bus
go to the go to the hospital and die and
then find that you have covered you will
be recorded as a cover death why would
they do that though
well right now the so
you know the road is hell is the rotel
is paid with good intentions i mean he's
mostly paid with bad intentions but
there's you know some good intentions
saving stones in there too
um
and the
the the stimulus bill that was intended
to help uh
with the hospitals that were being
overrun with with with code patients uh
created an incentive to
record something as covet that is
difficult to
say no to especially if your hospital is
going bankrupt for lack of other
patients
so the hospitals are in a bind right now
there's a bunch of hospitals are they're
following doctors as you were mentioning
they're
you know they're your is half full
you're
it's hard hard to make ends meet
so now you've got like
you know if i just check this box i get
eight thousand dollars
put on a ventilator for five minutes i
get thirty nine thousand dollars
back or or i to fire some doctors so
what's the what's this this is a tough
moral quandary
it's like what you can do
that's the situation we have
no
what what's the way out of this what do
you think is like if if you had the
president's ear or if people wanted to
just listen to you openly
what do you think is the way out of this
so let's let's clear up the data clear
up the data so
like i said uh something should be
required as code but only if it is uh
somebody has been tested uh
has received a positive positive cover
test not if they simply have symptoms
one of like 100 symptoms and then if
if it is a cover death it must be
separated or was this was coveted a
primary primary reason for death or did
they also have stage three cancer heart
disease emphysema
and got hit by a bus
and had covered
yeah i've read all this stuff about that
about them uh
diagnosing people as a covet death
despite other variables this is not a
this is not a this is not a a
question this is what is occurring
and where are you reading this from
where are you getting this from the
public health health officials have
literally said this
this is not this is not a question mark
right but this is never this is
unprecedented right like if someone had
the flu but also had a heart attack they
would assume that that person died of a
heart attack yes yeah so this is
unprecedented is this because
this is such a a popular i don't i don't
want to use that word the wrong way but
that's what i mean a popular subject
and financial incentives yes
and like so this is not some sort of it
a moral indictment of of sort of
hospital administrators it's just
they're in it they're
they're in a in a tough
in a tough spot here
um they actually don't have enough
patience
to
to pay everyone for it to with without
following following doctors and and
firing staff and yeah they're running
potentially going bankrupt so
so then they're like okay well the
stimulus bill says if you know we get
all this
you know money if we say
if if they if it's a cover death i'm
like okay
they coughed before they died
in fact they're not even diagnosed with
cover they simply if you had weakness a
cough
uh shortness of breath but frankly i'm
not sure how you die without those
things
yeah you yeah but there's so many
different
things that you could attribute to covet
too there's so many symptoms
there's diarrhea headaches dehydration
yeah cough
yes but to be clear you you don't even
need to have gotten a cover diagram
you simply need to have had one of many
symptoms
and then have died for some reason
and it's
covered
so then it makes the death count look
very high
and then we're then stuck in a bind
because it looks like the death count's
super high and not going down like it
should be
and now
so then we we should keep whatever
you know
keep you know the shelter in place stuff
there and and keep people in their home
you know confined people to homes so we
need to break out of this this we're
stuck in a loop yeah
and i think the way to break out of this
loop is to have clarity of information
clarity of information will certainly
help but
altering perceptions public perception
from people that are basically in a
panic there's a lot of essentially
well
at least a month ago we're clearly in a
panic i mean right where you know when
you look around april 5th
april 6th people were really freaking
out but here we are may
and may people are relaxing a little bit
yes they're realizing like hey um i
actually know a couple of people that
got it it was just a cough and i know
some people that got it where nothing
happened i know a lot of people have got
it
i know zero people who died that i mean
about no yeah a lot of people got it
yeah it's it's not what we feared
we feared something much worse yeah
that's correct so the adjustment's
difficult to make so you said
first of all we need real data we need
just just parse out the data don't don't
lump it all together no and then if if
you give if you get people
just
parse out the data better
clear clearer information
um
about uh like i said was this an actual
code of a diagnosis or was it a or did
they get the test and the test came back
positive or do they just have some
symptoms just parse those two out um and
then
parse out just uh if somebody died did
they die
did they did they even have a covet test
or or did they just have one of many
symptoms like like like how do you die
without weakness i don't know right it's
impossible basically yeah it's a good
point if you're gonna die you're gonna
have shortness of breath weakness and
you might cough a little
um so so was it quantified what was it
yeah that person did they actually have
a covert test and and the tests come
back positive and then um if if they
died did they uh die where where covert
was
um it didn't have to be the main course
but it was a significant contributor to
their death or was it not a significant
contributor to the death
right it's not as simple as just because
you had covet covet killed you
definitely not right yeah yeah i mean
people die all the time and they have
like flu and yes you know other colds
and well we don't say that they died of
those flu and other colds well that's
what's so weird absolutely it's so
popular
and i use that word in a weird way but
it's so popular that we've kind of
forgotten people die pneumonia every day
yeah people die of
the flu didn't take a break oh kovitz
got this i'm gonna sit this one out i'm
gonna be on the bench i'm gonna wait
until kovitz done before i jump back
into the game of killing people no the
flu is still here killing people i mean
ev every year in the world several
hundred thousand people die directly of
the flu yeah not not tangentially right
not every 61 000 in this country last
year yeah and we're only five percent of
the world
and then there's cigarettes so oh man
cigarettes not cigarettes will really
kill you that's a weird one right we're
terrified of this disease that were
projected it could potentially kill 100
if not 200 000 americans this year with
cigarettes kill 500 000 and you don't
hear a peep out of any politician
there's no one running for congress is
trying to ban cigarettes there's no one
running for senate that wants to put
some education plan in place it's going
to stop cigarettes in their tracks
yeah i mean
a long time like several years ago i
mean along with 10 10 years ago i helped
make a movie cold thank you for smoking
oh i saw that yeah um
it it
yeah
um
yeah it's crazy uh
smoking barbecuing alongside just bad
news it's not not good you know you're
turning your lungs into smoke smoked
beef and not great
um
so
um yeah
tylenol by the way also kills a lot of
people yeah what is the number for
tylenol over here um i'm not sure the
exact number but i believe it
until the opioid crisis i believe
tylenol was the number one killer of all
drugs
um because wow basically it's uh
if you have if you get drunk and take a
lot of tylenol
um acetaminophen essentially it causes
liver failure
so sevilla would like get
get wasted and then like have a headache
and then pop a tonic tylenol gardens
whoa yeah curtains is a funny word yeah
you know so but nobody's like you know
raging against tylenol
yeah
it's weird except acceptable deaths are
weird and that's the real the slippery
slope about this uh people shaming
people for wanting to go back to work
you know other people are gonna die well
if you drive do you drive oh well you
should stop driving because people die
from driving
so you know you definitely should fill
up all the swimming pools because like
50 people die every day in this country
from swimming so let's not swim anymore
yeah what is the
really dangerous we need to chop down
all the coconuts
coconuts kill 150 people every year yes
cut down all the coconut trees we need
those people yes it's at a certain point
in time it's like
we
yeah we're vulnerable and we're also
we we're also we have a finite existence
no matter what we do nobody lives
forever
right um
i mean the the the i mean i think you
want to look at say deaths as like the
but for this
uh disease whatever they would have
lived x number of years yeah you know so
um
you know if somebody dies when they're
they're they're 20 and could live till
80 they they lost 60 years
but if somebody dies when they're 80 and
they might live until 81 they last one
year yes so it's it's like how many life
years were lost
uh is is a probably you know the right
metric to
use i don't uh read my own comments but
i do read other people's comments and i
was reading this one little twitter beef
that was going on where someone was
saying that kovid takes an average of 10
years off people's lives and we should
appreciate those 10 years and then
someone else said that's not true
i'm sure it's not true yeah definitely
it's the twitter
but someone else said
the average age of people who die from
covid is older than the average age
people die
it's very let's say just say it's like
it's it's about the same
that's a beautiful way of looking at it
i mean it's it's unfortunate it sucks
but it sucks if grandpa dies of
alzheimer's or emphysema or leukemia it
sucks sure it sucks when someone you
love dies yes
but
i i'm
i mean actually if if this uh i think a
lesson to be taken here
that i think is quite important is that
if
um
if you have you know your great
grandparents and their their age and
grandparents really be careful with uh
with with uh
you know any kind of flu or cold or
something that that wouldn't is not
dangerous to
kids or young adults but is dangerous
too to help the elderly is um if
basically if your kids got a runny nose
they should stay away from their
grandparents
no matter what it is it's it's uh the
things that are
where a young immune system is has no
problem and an older one has has a
problem yeah and
um in fact a lot of the a lot of the
deaths are just are literally it's
tragic but they're they're intra family
um it's the the the
little little kid had it had a you know
called or flew and give it to grandpa
yeah yeah they have the family gathering
and they don't know that this is a big
deal but it's
it's just important to remember when you
get older your immune system is just not
that strong and uh
and and so just be be careful with your
with with your you know
loved ones or elderly and i think there
is some
true objective
um understanding of the immune system
and the ways to boost that immune system
and i really think that that
that information should be
that should be distributed in a way a
non-judgmental way but like look this is
this is a way that we can all like this
is a scientifically proven way that we
can boost our immune system and it might
save your life and it might save the
life of your loved ones and maybe we
could teach this to our grandparents and
our parents and and people that are
vulnerable you know vitamin c heat shock
proteins all these different variables
that we know contribute to a stronger
immune system
yeah um actually just um
a thing that that is is is tough uh
if
like when you as you get older it's it's
hard to
be
you pretend to put on weight
you know i certainly that's happening
with me you know like as the older i get
i'm like damn it's harder to stay lean
uh that's for sure
um
and and so actually being being
overweight is is a big deal yeah just uh
it's a fact uh
well
yeah the new york hospital said it was
the number one factor for severe uh
kovid symptoms was obesity that was
number one factor it is that that's yes
exactly
but it's also we live in a world where
people want to be
sensitive to other people's feelings so
yeah absolutely we don't want to
bring up the fact that
being fat's bad for you it's a judgment
on your food's great yeah i do love food
yeah and i mean i mean to be totally
frank i mean speaking for myself i'd i'd
rather eat tasty food and live a shorter
life
yeah you know
yeah those moments of enjoying a great
meal yeah and then even talking about
they're valuable they're worth something
yeah it's not we don't want to eat
soylent green and live to be 160.
tasty if it was great one of the best
things about life it really is yeah it's
an art form as well it's like
fine food
it's a it's a it's a
it's
a delicious sand castle it's temporary
it doesn't last very long but there's
something about it that's very pleasing
yeah yeah um
yeah i mean
i i don't know what what advice to give
like um maybe smaller have tasty food
with smaller amounts of it
yeah and
i think
regulated feeding windows really the way
to go some sort of an intermittent
fasting approach sure when i started
doing that i i
i i found myself to be quite a bit
healthier when i've deviated from that
i've gained weight so how what's what's
uh 16 hours well 16 hours yeah
so like at night or yeah yeah yeah so i
get to a certain point and then i count
out i usually uh hit the stopwatch on my
phone and then i look at uh 15 hours and
i'm like okay got an hour before i can
eat yeah and so
anything in between that is just water
or coffee
actually you know like um
this may be a useful bit of advice for
for people but uh eating before you go
to bed is a real bad idea and actually
negatively affects your sleep yeah um
and it can actually cause uh it
heartburn that you don't even know is
happening and and that subtle heartburn
uh affects your sleep because you're
you're horizontal and your body's
digesting
so if you want to improve the quality of
your sleep um and and um
you know uh you know
be healthier uh it's it's do not eat
right before we go to sleep yeah it's
like one of the worst things you could
do i had some of the biggest mistakes
i've ever met i've i've done that uh
particularly after comedy shows i'm
starving i'll come home and i'll eat and
then i go to bed and i just feel like
[ __ ] and i wake up in the middle of the
night it's gonna it's gonna crush your
sleep and it's gonna it's gonna damage
your
uh pilot your pyloric sphincter and your
esophagus and it's it's it's so
in fact
drinking and then going to sleep is
that's one of the worst things you could
yes um
so
uh just
try to avoid drinking and and
you know
um
small amounts of alcohol that
evidence suggests it's not it doesn't
have a
negative effect i put in the same
category as delicious food it kind of
makes things a little more fun
yeah yeah i like it i mean some of the
people some of the people who have left
the longest you know um there's a woman
in france who i think
maybe has the record or close to it and
she had a glass of wine every day every
day you know yeah
small small amounts is fine um
but um
yeah this is like a i i learned this
like quite late in life it's like just
avoid having alcohol and avoid eating
at least two or three hours before going
to sleep and your quality of life will
your quality of sleep will improve and
your general health will improve a lot
for sure this is a it's a big deal and i
think not widely not widely known do you
have time to
exercise um
a little bit
um do you train or anything
um i do although i haven't seen
for a while but
um
yeah especially yeah from out like uh
you know say we're working on starship
or something in south texas and i'm just
living in my i got a little
little house there in bukuchika village
um
and i don't have much to do so
we're like i'm working and i was like
dude just lift some weights or something
you know um
maybe uh i i i
like i don't some people love running i
don't love running
um but what do you like to do exercise
wise
um
too totally frank i wouldn't exercise at
all if i could but if if i
i'd prefer not to exercise but if i'm
going to exercise and you know lift some
weights and
um
and then
kind of run on the treadmill and maybe
watch a show that you know if there's a
compelling show that like pulls you in
right right right yeah that's a good
thing to do yeah watch a good movie or
yeah yeah episode of black mirror or
something like that that's great man
don't watch black mirror before going to
bed either well don't watch black mirror
today
it's too [ __ ] accurate yeah exactly
it's like wait this already happened in
real life
yeah they're too close it's too close
well even didn't jamie did you say that
the the guy who makes black mirror
mics off uh yeah yeah he said he it's
not a good time to start season six yeah
he wants to hold off because
reality he's nailed it is black mirror
oh man it's like he's gonna have to like
re reassess
and and attack it from a different angle
yeah
you should try something that's fun to
do that's not just like
like learn a martial art or something
like that i did martial arts when i was
kid like did you would you um
i did
taekwondo i did karate uh kaika shrinkai
all right cool and um
judo um
also you you really branched out yeah um
so
um
and did brazilian jiu jitsu briefly did
you yeah where i made in palo alto
really yeah oh no [ __ ] i was gonna
suggest that that's a great thing for
people like that's a thing about jiu
jitsu if you look at it from the outside
you think oh a bunch of meat heads
strangling each other sure but they're
some of the smartest people i know or
jiu jitsu fiends because they they get
they first of all they get introduced to
it because usually either they want to
exercise or learn some self-defense but
then they realize that it's essentially
like a language
with your body like you're having an
argument with someone with some sort of
a physical language
and it's really complex and the more
access to vocabulary and the sharper
your words are sure the the more you'll
succeed in these ventures that's really
also an accurate analogy of what jiu
jitsu is yeah i mean i kind of i mean
probably like a lot of people uh for the
the way uh early day uh the first mma
fights and joyce gracie and he was like
incredible and it was like just like
technique yeah yeah it was like you know
winning against people way bigger and
that kind of thing it's just like oh
this is cool it was what martial arts
were supposed to be when we were as we
were kids yeah when you saw bruce lee
[ __ ] up all these big giant guys like
wow martial arts allow you to beat
someone far bigger and stronger than you
right
most of the time that's not real
especially if they know martial arts too
it's like oh no yes but in the ufc when
hoist gracie
off of his back was strangling dan
severin with his legs he was like holy
[ __ ] yeah this guy's being pinned by
this big giant wrestler and he wraps his
legs around his neck and chokes him to
the point the guy has to surrender yeah
amazing yeah it was amazing
i mean horse got beaten up pretty bad in
some of those he did well he definitely
had some rough fights but he won he won
yeah
he's a legend and but what it showed in
i mean i'm a huge lover of jiu jitsu
what it showed is that there is a method
for uh
for
diffusing these situations with
technique and and knowledge yeah and i
think it's also a great way to exercise
too because it's almost like the
exercise is secondary to the learning of
the thing the the exercises like you
want like and you want to develop
strength and conditioning just so that
you could be better at doing the thing
and the analogy that i use is like if
you imagine if you had a race car
and you could actually give the race car
better handling and more horsepower just
from your own focus and effort sure
that's really what it's like yeah
totally yeah
when am i going to have my my kids i
should say i sent my kids to
uh jiu jitsu uh since they were like i
don't know six oh really yeah oh that's
awesome yeah
it's it's a great thing to learn it
really is seems like a good yes yeah
maybe something like i mean even if you
just have someone who hits that holds
the pads for you like you get a workout
in and to be fun
um when am i going to be able to buy one
of them roadsters when's that happening
well i can't you know
say exactly when but uh
we got to get
you know
those this cover thing's kind of
throwing us for a loop i'm sure um so
um
not to blame everything in the code but
um
it's you know
certainly set us back on on progress for
you know some number of months um
the i mean things we've got to get get
done
uh ahead of roadster are um
you know ramping up model y production
um that'll be a great great car it is a
great car
getting the
berlin gigafactory built
and and
also building y
getting expanding the shanghai factory
which is going great
and um
get the you know there's a cyber truck
semi truck roadster
um
roaster is kind of like dessert
so
like we we gotta get the
you know eating potatoes and greens and
stuff
you know like
but roaster comes before cyber truck
i mean i think we should do cyber truck
first before before road before started
interesting
i'm not mad at that some other things
for roadster uh they're they're you know
the tri-motor
uh plaid powertrain we're gonna have
that in model s
uh so that's like part one of the
ingredients that's needed for for
roadsters the the plaid powertrain the
more advanced bat you know battery
vacuum kind of thing i wanted to ask you
about this before i forgot what there's
a company that's called apex is taking
your teslas and
they're
giving it a wider base and
wider tires and a little bit more
advanced suspension
sure how do you feel about that are you
guys do you work with them are you cool
with those people yeah i mean just i'm
off yeah go ahead they're
jazzing stuff up with carbon fiber and
doing a bunch of interior choices
you're cool with you can't [ __ ] with
that you don't have time so is it good
that someone comes along and has a sort
of specialty operation yeah i got no
problem that's what it's called right
it's like jmg is it called apex yeah i
gotta unplug performance as apex that's
right unplug performance yeah yeah you
could for sure um
you know lighten the car up and uh
improve to tire traction and have you
seen that company's stuff what they do i
don't know specifically but there's it's
pretty dope yeah they make a pretty dope
looking they take model s and they they
widen it and give it a bunch of carbon
fiber that's it right there
that looks pretty nice yeah it does
now the the plaid
version of the model s you are you going
to widen the track and doing a bunch
do a bunch of different i know you guys
are testing at the nurburgring can you
not talk about that well i think we got
to leave that for
you know proper sort of product unveil i
understand yeah i understand um last
time you were here you convinced me to
buy a tesla i bought it and it's [ __ ]
insane oh great glad you like it um
i don't it's not just pretty fun it's
like i the way i've described it is it
makes other cars seem stupid
they just seem dumb like i love dumb
things i love dumb cars like i love
campfires yeah i love campfires i have a
1993 porsche that's air-cooled sure it's
like re it's not that fast it's really
slow compared to the tesla yeah really
so it's really quite slow yeah but
there's something
engaging about the mechanical
this is like the the gears and it's very
it's very analog but it's so stupid in
comparison to the tesla like when i want
to go somewhere in the model s i hit the
gas and just goes
yeah it just it like violates time
yeah yeah um
yeah you've tried it like ludicrous plus
and stuff yeah yeah cool
oh yeah we did just did a software
update where it'll do it like a cheetah
stance so uh yeah so it's it because
it's got a
dynamic air suspension so it lowers the
back oh jesus
yeah just like uh like a sprinter
basically right like what do you do if
you're a sprinter you're going to hunker
down and then
uh so
i shaved like a 10th of a second off
zero six i mean like you know
it is pretty fun it's so i've taken so
many people and i'm like i take them for
the holy [ __ ] moment i'm like you ready
like hang on there and then a stomp on
the gas i've never felt anything like it
it's confusing
yeah it really is
the the instant torque the instant
torque and just the sheer acceleration
is baffling it's baffling it's baffling
they've never felt it no it's faster
than falling it's crazy it's so fast
it's a roller coaster yeah and my family
yells at me when i stomp the gas like um
i tell my kids i'm like you want to feel
it you want to feel it like do it do it
do it my wife's like don't do it
yeah and even if i just do it on the
highway for a couple of seconds that's
pretty exciting yeah it's very it's like
having a roller coaster on tap you know
it really is like a roller coaster on
top yeah without the loopty loops but
it's the the pinning to your seat it
seems like you're not supposed to be
able to experience that from some sort
of a can you know a consumer vehicle
that you can just a regular person could
buy if you have the money
it seems too too crazy
and then the idea of this roadster is a
half of a second faster than that
yeah that's madness
well if that roads with a roadster we're
going to do some things that are kind of
unfair
so
we're going to take some things from
like
you know from uh kind of like rock
rocket world and put them on the car so
oh i read about that explain that like
what do you do well like i said we can't
oh the product unveiled right here but
but
it's gonna do some things that aren't
fair
and then
the the when we do the unveil of the
roadster
let me just say that anyone who's been
waiting they won't be sorry
it's they won't be sorry oh i'm sure
well anything that goes zero to sixty
what is it one point nine is that the
zero 0-60 that's the base model that's
good
what's the top of the food chain model
okay okay
faster than that let's just say faster
yeah that seems so crazy to me now what
was it like when the dude threw the
steel balls at the window and they were
supposed to not break and it broke
well
yeah i mean i know
any circumstances
are you know you know that our demos are
authentic
[Laughter]
so i was not expecting that and i and
then i think i muttered under my breath
you didn't get mad though
no you didn't steve jobs it
um
no i i i definitely swore uh but you
know i didn't think the mic would pick
it up but it did um
and uh
but so
like we practiced this
you know behind the scenes yeah i would
like it tesla we don't do we don't do
like tons of practice for for our demos
because we we work we're working on the
cars like we you know we're building
new technologies and and improving the
the fundamental products so we're not
spending it like doing like hundreds of
you know practice things or anything
like that we don't have time for that um
but the the
just hours before the demo um both franz
uh you know uh is a head of design and
and i were in the studio throwing steel
balls at the window and it's bouncing
right off
um and like okay this seems pretty good
seems like we got it okay
um
and then we think what happened was that
um
when we
when when franz hit the the
the door with the sledgehammer
you know sure like like this is this is
like yeah yeah yeah exoskeleton
you know high strength hardened steel
you can literally
take wind up with a sledgehammer you
know full
double-handed sledgehammer
and hit the door and there's not even a
dent it's cool
but we think that that cracked the
corner of the glass
at the bottom
and then
once you crack the corner of the glass
that you just came over
so
uh
then when you threw the bowl that that's
what cracked the glass so it didn't go
through though it didn't go through
that's true that's true it didn't
shatter the whole thing like a regular
window would either which would just
dissolve yeah right
so in hindsight the ball should have
been first sledgehammer second yeah
yeah you live you learn yeah exactly
listen man uh we've taken up a lot of
your time you had a child yeah recently
it's amazing that you had the time to
come down here and i really appreciate
that i appreciate everything you do man
i i'm i'm glad you're out there and uh i
really appreciate you coming down here
and sharing your perspective well i
think you got a great show thanks for
having me on thank you my pleasure my
pleasure elon musk ladies and gentlemen
good night
all right that should get a little i
should get a little play
that was great